こんにちは、ドクターはじめだ
皆はハッピーターンというお菓子を知っているか？
それには
中毒性のあるとんでもないお菓子だ。
普通のハッピーターンもあるんですけども
ちょっと前にこういうのが出ました
250%パウダーMAXハッピーターン
このお菓子の周りに
粉、パウダーがかかっている
で、このパウダーによって味付けがされており
1回食べてしまうと癖になる
そのパウダーの量が250%増量されているのが
こちらのハッピーターン250パウダーMAX
食べてみよう
うんまww
うまいわwwwwwwwww
粉だけで良くなるわけですよ。
粉がすごい美味しいこのお菓子は。
パウダーが付いてしまった
わたくしドクターはじめ
皆さんの想像している以上に大好きすぎて
私はなんとかして
なんということだ！
禁断のパウダーを
なんて罪な男だ！
私ドクターはじめ、罪な男
ﾊｧｧｧｧｱｱｱ!!!
ｳｨｨｨｨｨｨｲｲｲｲｲｲ!!!
それくらい好きなんだ
というわけで今回、私は
ｱｩﾗ!
はいというわけでハッピーターン250%を100袋集めました
これコンビニ限定なので
コンビニに行ったとしても
売ってても5,6袋とか
多くても10袋くらいなので非常に手に入れるのが大変だった
私は静岡中のコンビニを1日かけて集め回った
それがこの結果だ
これだけの量集めるのにどれだけの体力を費やしたことか！
いやホントにかなり大変だったがようやくこれだけ集められたので
今回、私の夢を叶えるために
この大量のハッピーターンから私は今回パウダーだけを抽出しようと思う
ハッピーターンの粉作れるみたいな話もあるんですよ
塩と砂糖と味の素かな
コンソメ？わかんないなんか
ヴォエ！
ハッピーターンの粉を調味料だけで作れるみたいな話があったんですけど
まがい物に過ぎんだろう
私が食べたいのは本物のハッピーターンのパウダーのみ
まがい物などいらん！
パウダーだけを抽出、サルベージし
丼いっぱいのパウダーを作り一気に食べたいと思う
また一つ科学の歴史のページが
開く瞬間だ
はいではやっていこうと思う
ハッピーターンはちゃんと責任を持って食べます
この歯ブラシでハッピーターンに付いているパウダーをここに落としていくという作戦だ
かなり数があるのでさらっとやっていこうと思う
じゃあ落としてみます
あー全然　全然落ちる全然落ちる
歯ブラシもハッピーターンのパウダーを落とすために生まれてくるとは思ってないだろうね絶対。
あーなんか意外とイケる気がしました
やっぱ250%っていうのが多分デカい気がしますね
めちゃくちゃ落ちます
ではどんどんやっていこう
地味だなぁ...
ﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌwww
まじでアホでしょ
しゃっしゃっ しゃっしゃっしゃしゃ
しゃっ しゃっしゃっしゃしゃ
ｴﾋﾞﾊﾞｰﾃﾞｨ↑
別にこれなんか筆とか$'%#（聞き取り不能）
ww書初めのw
これハート入ってないんじゃね？
めっちゃレアなんだろうね
よし。いやでも結構半分まで来てるよ多分。
やばいよ
え？！わーーホントだ
皆さんご覧ください
いや多分10袋目くらいかな
全然出なかったんですけどようやくハート型のハッピーターンが出ました
んあーーっエグイエグイエグイエグイ
ほんとエグイ....
そうだな
まあ一言で言うと
幸せの
折り返し
ですね
まあ決して1人でできることとは思ってないし
色んな人達の協力があってこそ完成した実験だと僕は思います
やってる時はあんまり幸せじゃなかったんですけど
まあいざ終わってみると
たくさんの幸せが
ターンしてきましたね
皆にも幸せが行き届くといいなと思ってます
ありがとうございます
というわけで無事ハッピーパウダーのサルベージに成功しました
ホントニタイヘンダッタヨォ
なめてた
100袋全部は使わなかったんですけど
中々かなり50,60袋くらい使ってようやく
丼いっぱいのハッピーパウダーを抽出することに成功しました
何個か食べちゃったんですけど
ハートのハッピーターンが
60袋中6個くらいしか出てないので
かなりの低確率だということがわかりました
まあこのブラッシングアイテムを見る通り
かなりの戦いだったことが目に見てわかると思います
丼いっぱいのハッピーパウダーを抽出するのに、約
本当にね中身全部これですから一切のあれがもうない状態でございます
ほれ
ようやく念願の私の夢を叶える時が来たーー
では早速至福の時間をいただくとします
いただきます！
ｴｯﾍwちょっと
いただきます
いやほんと食べますね
ｱｧｯ
おぉぉええ...
なぜだ・・・
美味しくないぞ.......
ううぇなんか濃い濃い濃い....
なん...なんでなんで（当たり前だろ）
あ、うめー（大嘘）
というわけで今回の実験でわかったことは
ハッピーパウダーは食べ過ぎると美味しくないということがわかりました
クソーー！
このハッピーパウダーどうしようかと言いますと
まあ今後の実験に使えるかもしれないかなり重要な資源だ
こちらはカメラを湿気から守る防湿庫という私の部屋に研究室があるのだが
その中に湿らないようにして
カメラと一緒に入れておきます
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊ